good day I'm Colonel Gerry Morlock the
director of the combat studies institute
you're about to use a video series which
our instructors have prepared for the
sole purpose of approving your
presentation of M 610 devolution of
modern warfare we've taken care to make
the course that you teach is similar to
the one taught at Fort Leavenworth as
possible and choose to add these tapes
to your libraries in order to give you
every advantage as you prepare to teach
this new course these tapes are similar
to the weekly train obsessions which we
utilize to prepare our instructors here
at Fort Leavenworth my intent for the
tape sessions was to provide you
insights and tips on ways to approach
the lessons of M 6:10 that were not
available in the instructor notes I've
drawn various instructors military and
civilian into the sessions based upon
their specific expertise and historical
background they were asked to just talk
to the lesson structure and content
giving you some additional information
on the historical context and different
views on how to approach the lessons
these tapes will provide you a wealth of
knowledge and direction that will
significantly improve your readiness to
teach our new history course one word of
caution regarding how to use these
training tapes they are not designed to
be substituted for your instruction
during the individual lessons of the
course as instructor preparation tapes
train-the-trainer material if you will
they are inappropriate for direct
instruction to students and are not
intended for that purpose our intent
with these tapes is to improve your
ability to lead the students seminars by
sharing tips and advice for some highly
qualified experts a combat studies
institute stands ready to provide
whatever additional expertise or
assistance that you may require and
we've included the Institute's phone
mail and email contact information on
the tape if you should need it good luck
with evolution of Modern Warfare course
have a good time all right
today my name is some techno Scott
Stevenson I'm the the course author
a resident Military District course at
CGS see coming new today and hopefully
provide the knowledge that I might not
be able to provide this session our tech
knowledge in Martin and dr. Sam Lewis
both of them will give it a little
intellectual credibility this group at
this late stage in your course it's time
to start thinking about how you've seen
these these sessions we've had here on
tape we're thinking about a reward
program we think perhaps this session
might deserve at least consideration for
the homeless trio on tape during our
start non-resident CGS see instruction
and instructor prep tapes nothing take
this seriously this is the last lesson
this is the wrap-up for the course that
you post these students a chance to tie
the threads that you've offered them all
through the course and so I think you
want to allocate some time to that what
are the themes that you think they
should things they should have pulled
out of the course but also you want to
hit the material because in my mind I
think Sam and Jim would agree with me
this this lesson potentially one of the
most interesting one of most provocative
it's about the way the army thinks about
its business how we got to the way we
are today the way we operate today the
doctrine that we use today in large part
based on the way the army came out of
the Vietnam War how it assessed its
experiencing in the Vietnam War
it sets the new challenges faced by the
Warsaw Pact and then how how were they
going to adapt to a new world going in
60 70s and 80s again this lesson tells
us a lot about the way we think about
our business today I think it's
worthwhile and a way to come back to the
themes that you talked about at the very
beginning the course what are the
relationships between history theory and
doctrine I like to start by asking Sam
what kind of approaches in general you
used to go on after this lesson first of
all I'd agree with agree with your
observations
this lesson will stand up on its own as
a piece for looking at the US military
after the Vietnam War but it's also an
ideal opportunity to examine where we've
been why we're at
at this particular this particular point
why we are this one and what indicators
are out there for the use of force into
the future so I always try to use this
lesson to wrap it all up
one of the key notions in this lesson is
is there an American Way of war and
through throughout the course we've been
using the text by Russell widely to
examine his particular view on the
subject for those new instructors out
there trust you students and trust the
readings let them attempt to come up
with an evaluation of whether there
isn't a unique American way or is it
part of something larger a Western Way
of war if it is different
how so and why what is it like when
Saddam Hussein or a potential enemy of
the United States looks at the US
military what do they see do they see
certain tendencies are certain things
expected and can we ourselves rely upon
those to be used in the future that's
one motion
I found that this lesson
always for me ends up coming back my
students bring it back a lot to the Gulf
War your instructor notes talked about
maybe how how does the Gulf War reflect
what's occurred after after Vietnam and
remembering that Korea and Vietnam were
not the military experiences we might
have liked them to event it's not
unusual that many of our students will
turn to looking at the Gulf War which
turns out the way we do want it to turn
out so don't be afraid if it goes that
direction that that's not too unusual
happens here to North rias that it's
healthy and awesome and in many ways one
can maintain that Desert Storm
represents a flowering of American
military culture whether you like it or
not and you notice in in the
introduction to this week's lesson the
author quoted colonel dr. Swain and
pointing out some of our more
predictable trends the over reliance on
numbers the over reliance on technology
the
in German it's at Bush stable the
regimented process-oriented the way we
like to see it ourselves
dr. Swain like pointed out that we all
like to see ourselves as patents
Guderian's and Rommels and it comes as a
shock when someone someone suggests that
we are the slow plodding methodical
players
we're bludgeon them to death instead of
the bull rapier thrust we like that I
this is a good discussion question you
can get a lot of mileage out of this I
think you particularly can if you've got
someone who is in seventh Corps I mean
all they have to do is have red Schwartz
cops book and the treatment of general
Frank's and Schwarzkopf book
and you can get an argument going and by
the way used term argument just as a
euphemism for discussion discussion is
just an argument among civilized people
but it's a you can get a great one going
just on that that disagreement there
because what Schwarzkopf wanted Franks
to be was Pat and he wasn't as I think
Swain point out there weren't any
patents in that or if they were doctrine
and training made them behave in a more
regimented manner you know Scott you do
something in your class I mean when I
was a new instructor here you you
brought out some charts and things where
you show I mean you show the beginnings
of this regimented peace in our army in
the days when you and I came in you know
we're back from the 7576 timeframe and
the
the cornerstone doctrine manuals that we
use that and the manuals that flowed
from that showed that regimentation Sam
talked about you know we just came out
of the 73 war peace not long ago we
talked about that and some of the things
that pop out there that the one that
really pops to mind is the Sagar and you
know all of a sudden there was a there
was an anti-tank missile out there that
can kill an m60 tank
Wrigleyville and in the Army responded
to it by becoming to me more regimental
like Sam talked about going numbers
locust yeah why don't you share that I
think that's a real good if I could make
a point that you want to allocate time
in this lesson toward wrap it up and you
want to talk about where is the army
right now and what do we know what can
we project about the future war pip but
the centerpiece of lesson quite clearly
is Herbert's deciding what has we done
the Leavenworth paper camouflage code
talks about the debate over these the 76
edition of the FM hundred f5 and you
need to give that it's due because that
piece is a real case studying on the way
the army thinks about doctrine you've
got to set that up though and again this
Jim says has said in a way you have to
refer back to the 73 war shaken the way
out I think she even have to have to go
back farther than that to what shaped
the mind of the guy who's going to build
the doctrine that the army takes into
the post-vietnam here this this less
than a large part is about a guy named
de PUE many of you may not have ever
heard of the guy but : Powell said he
more than anybody shaped the
post-vietnam army made it into the
success story we took of the Gulf War
again that's that's a maybe a
controversial point he obviously if you
read in the herbert pc and that wouldn't
be a fun guy to work for
he's abrasive he's aggressive he's
opinionated but he's the guy who shaped
that document and you really have to set
this lesson up I talk about what shapes
the
the worldview of this guy as he takes on
the business of remaking the army after
Vietnam what do you think the key things
handed that shape the way he looked at
doctrine in its role I find a few
fascinating as I'm sure your students we
will find them fascinating one of the
things you can ask the students is what
sort of a man was he
what were the influences upon him I
usually wait for a bit to ask that I'll
start off this lesson with the question
what was the strategic situation for the
US military and the US Army in 1972 and
1973 what was the major threat what were
the results of our failure in Vietnam
what were the significance of
congressional action to do away with the
draft
I use that as a building block to start
out then I try to get into the realm of
institutions when we started this class
off we considered the development of the
War Department and later general staffs
to be a great sign of progress of the
wave of the future
1973 comes along they are no longer
there is this progress what does it
represent what is a TRADOC what does it
do
what's an integration Center what
happened to the old war departments and
general staffs okay is this part and
parcel of the American military
culture and experience that's worth
looking at at this point I usually bring
in de PUE
who was he why did he think this way I
asked the students if they have known
anyone like de PUE did they what was it
like working for is the pew typical of
the US Army officer corps or is he
untypical exceptional where does he
stand as a symbol in the evolution of
modern warfare is he our Napoleon is he
our vodka or is he our George
Steinbrenner we have gotten some mileage
out of that one in the past George
Steinbrenner that's the way I start off
you know there's this question of who
was this guy does a do the students know
who he is I like to ask him a favor
Tokido Pew fighting position yes I've
asked because most of us at one time or
another have had to have had to dig one
of those and makes you wonder well who
was this guy was he yeah and that's
probably the first place I ever thought
about him as I was trying to dig a de
PUE foxhole in the red clay of Georgia
and when calling him a number of readers
you can you can reach out and kind of
get your students attention you'll find
it and I'm sure you've already found by
now that things that you can reduce to a
personal level with students and get
them mixed we give them highly involved
so that's one way I found you can reach
out and grab these guys in this lesson
it's just kind of after you do that that
overview
you can reach out or something like that
you know Scot you asked about background
and I think with almost any military
actor that you have to look at what's
occurred in their life and how that then
drives how they how they think I mean we
grew up in the post-vietnam generation
you and I and that affects our thinking
as military men you know I was in the
Gulf War that affects my thinking and I
think you have to examine or get your
students to examine those watershed
events into pews life and that's
probably World War two and Vietnam and
you know how the army performed in
Vietnam which wasn't a positive thing
versus some things that happened in
World War two which was a more positive
event I think shape depew's look at the
world rip yeah it really does I think
you see it in the FM yeah I'm constantly
struck by his his experience in war ii
and his interpretation of it he fought
in in France and Germany in 1944 1945 as
a staff officer in the 9th division the
division that first committed had a
pretty poor combat record was a series
of division commander one relieved after
another he describes that division is a
casualty-producing machine producing
American casualties that's how badly
advice that we saw the explosion of
leaders and groups of being mediocre in
his opinion and needing constant
detailed guidance he contrasted that
with the Germans within his mine knew
that all the techniques combined arms
warfare knew how to cite fighting
positions knew how to to make them make
the most of small unit leadership and he
said the American army didn't look very
well by contrast in fact they see he
said really what we did our infantry did
during that war was provide escorts for
our forward observers and we blasted our
way slowly across northern France into
Germany again going back to this idea of
perhaps of America where war being
bludgeoning the enemy
something more akin to maneuver warfare
he came out of that with enormous
respect for the Germans and some kind of
some reservations about what kind of
doctrine would be appropriate for
Americans he goes on to Vietnam where he
be successful by all accounts and he
comes up with a technique of the pylon
made contact with the smallest possible
force and then piled masses of firepower
and crew back on there it was seemingly
successful him but of course Vietnam is
not the war he's worried about like most
of the army this is a painful operation
perhaps to him he's got he's got the
face when he takes over TRADOC a brand
new challenge so what do you see him
thinking about what the role for the new
TRADOC what does that get to do for the
army and the post-vietnam occurred
before addressing that I'd like to just
throw out a brief idea
how to get to a number okay number of
these issues and I sometimes I start off
the second hour with this question and I
ask what are the major factors that
influence the creation of the 1976
manual Depew obviously the one we should
have talked about him in the first hour
what's the nature of the Warsaw Pact how
good are they what do we think about
them what's the significance of the 73
arab-israeli war why all of a sudden is
the US Army and the US Air Force
cooperating setting up a special
cooperation office not too far from
Norfolk
I think that's an indicator of how bad
things were in 73 and finally the German
army both from depends experiences with
it in world war ii and for what the
Bundeswehr is thinking about the defense
of western europe from 1970 through 1976
as a facilitator your job is to not list
these down on the blackboard in germany
in fashion but to draw forth these
responses from your students and
encourage your students to mention these
and those other factors which I've
forgotten or don't know because I'm not
smart enough to but those are those are
four or five were the ones that I go
with to pew and the 76 manual is it's
your question for me the big question in
my mind is is this manual and aberration
or is this a typical American product
why that mean by that I mean a product
of the US Army and I try not to force my
opinions on the students I'll let them
wrestle with this is he in fact a new
George Steinbrenner the boss dictates
everything who does not trust his
subordinates and for those lawyers out
there I would like to say that I love
and respect George what's in the 76
manual and why is it this way there's a
certain part of our society that comes
out of World War two fascinated by
technology numbers crunching and our
ability to make the atomic bomb for
instance or put overwhelming masses of
firepower on a certain certain grid on a
map if you go back and look at the 76
manual
there's a lot of that systems analysis
type of thinking in the man
I'll frequently ask the students for
comments about what the 76 manual
represented but usually I get the best
response by asking them what the
response of the US Army was to the 76
manual and the author of the Leavenworth
paper does a pretty good job they didn't
like it why didn't they like it well if
you talk to the oh well if you talk to
your fathers and uncles who who were
around at the time they'll tell you that
the 76 manual was the first manual that
told them how to fight that did not
trust them as soldiers and men to use
their judgment their experience the
officer corps resented it for that
reason
Alexander Haig was a general alive at
the time and he was powerful enough to
stand up to de Putte and TRADOC and he
said there's nothing in this manual
about leadership the principles of war
are not mentioned it has a lot of
mathematical formulations but it doesn't
talk about what it really takes to
leading in in battle I sound like that I
think that was probably a decisive
moment when someone that big can come
out public and say that
so that's the way I am I think one of
the key things phrases Sam used there
was the how to fight because we end up
coming out of this 76 manual with a
whole series of books which we commonly
refer to as have fight pills for the
company level the battalion level the
brigade level and it tells you what it
is you're supposed to do it's like the
emplacement and use of a claymore mine
but at the division level and you know I
think that represents even got an even
greater frame of thinking like that in
the American military system beyond the
pew I think if you look at the Vietnam
War you see this this hang-up with
numbers body count a tangible something
you can touch we see it today in this
college where people want a grading
standard that you can reach out and
touch and feel and see in shape and if
they're comfortable with that and I
think that's part of our military the
qualifier it's not work bill that's
right in and that comes from this period
of time I think but I don't Maddie
because as part of our culture to me you
always take your culture I guess I guess
in this Kayla successful army does
reflect the culture which it counts and
the ends we certainly see it but that's
one of taken you see to any other piece
that sets us up and I against the
October war tune I did the pews original
agenda taken over credit has not
necessarily rewrite doctrine all of a
sudden the new sense of urgency comes
always an anchor report so we see the
seventy three warning seems to indicate
that our army has spent ten years in the
jungle and lost an entire March or
several marches to the Soviets who are
now have these formidable weapon systems
again as you point out with tech
technology they logically oriented the
military it's scary what we see in the
deserts of Sinai and the Golan Heights
be in peace
far better infantry fighting vehicle
than anything we have
new air defense systems like which we've
got a hint of how good they are over
Hanoi and Haiphong but they're
tremendously effective against the
Israeli Air Force PMP which is our
engineers don't have anything like them
and again as you pointed out the sagar
we don't have anything with tow missile
perhaps mounted on helicopters can
approximate it but the Soviets clearly
have got something seems that seems at
first as effective and easily portable
available in vast numbers they and they
are pulling those weapon systems in
Eastern Europe and mass quantities and
it's a scary prospect well you and I as
students at TRADOC during this period of
time I mean I'm sure you got at the
armor school I know I got a damn venturi
school I mean as a mech instrument they
spent hours teaching you how to run a
Sagar watch
I mean how to watch for the puff of
smoke the slow thing coming at you back
down it was a gradual that's right I
mean they spent hours teaching us we
became so focused on the weapons from
that war and you see in the manuals I
mean you've got the graphs that you like
to show that show us if you're sitting
here the chance of you being killed is
as much and if you're sitting here the
chances this much and those kind of very
exact calculations are very much a part
of deep you stray tactic and the focus
back on the 73 war it's very easy to see
if I just think back into my basic
course in 70s it's a shock way through
our wait a bit it did and that's I mean
that's one of the things we're talking
about here with these how to fight
manuals
those are his that's his response
in the Army's doctrinal response to
those eight there's another piece to
this as well is the Army as worried as
it is about the threat is recently when
the pew takes over trainer has recently
lost some super cure it battles
it hasn't been able to say very clearly
what it needs to face that threat so we
lost the battle over the mbt-70 it lost
the battle over the Sheyenne helicopter
so the Army's doing a bad job on Capitol
Hill and how do you argue for the kind
of what position if you need well the
piece says doctoring could play a role
in that as well what would you add on
that anything I think there is a
tendency to forget what a rude shock the
73 war was not just for the US Army but
for the US military and other militaries
around the world to get the reports and
on the new weapons systems in the past
I've had some success asking the
students about their branch what was
happening in your branch because of the
73 war or returning from Vietnam to help
set the stage and get a lot of mileage
out of that I can recall the armored
school in the mid 70s as a young
lieutenant having having to memorize the
position of every single vehicle and
motorized rifle regiment in the approach
march and then
and how does it look in attack formation
being able to identify where the BMPs
are out the t-72s and then having to
crank it some level of detail what we
call the time battle caucus and we still
use it there certain extent but figuring
out the force ratio is the mathematical
calculations how many weapons system is
firing at what rate and what kind of
engagement area will will quote this is
a big tournament service that number of
targets as they come roaring into your
engagement area and comes back to the
kind of numerical approach to fighting
but and you know I've had an amazing
young budding lieutenants like us are
imbued with this in the basic course and
how we go into the into the army and you
talk about how it's not received well
out in the army you tell a story about
popping out there as a staff officer
okay reflect what would you like there
all right all right to put it a negative
of what we're talking about versus the
Army at large how they accept this and
what's being taught in the TRADOC
schools is CPX in the the I won't tell
what unit was in but as a brand new s3
just out of the Vietnam advanced course
we were taught to put all our weapon
systems up front because that's the only
way we can get the right for freshers to
take on the anticipated attack of
motorized rifle regiment reinforced my
battalion commander said looking at the
defensive problem we need to keep
reserve you can't predict how this
battle is going to go we common sense
prudence everything I learned says we
need to keep reserve Rathod sir the
documents coming out from the armored
school says put your weapons isn't out
there where they can service the act
with number targets so we put all at
that time three company teams online the
enemy came but then another enemy force
blew in from through a flank from our
unit to our right and all of a sudden
he's behind us we had no force to
respond to that
it was a game set and match it was over
yeah we've done the doctrinal thing and
we've been wrong we looked at this was a
CPX done in front of the division
commander our battalion clearly had lost
the fight and I was deeply humiliated
about putting my battalion commander
recommending the doctrinal solution and
really common military sense would would
have would give them a better solution
Lizzie that that goes I think to a
mixture of what we talked about here in
the last little while the battalion
commander out there goes it doesn't make
sense to me but since his training it's
not really soldiers lives fine we we try
what the doctrine says but that's why I
think some of these guys were resistant
it didn't allow for the common sense you
called it leadership it didn't allow for
leadership for common sense for looking
at a piece of ground and doing
situational awareness it said now you're
using buzz let's write this down here's
a piece of ground we drew it out this
nice chart show you how to set up your
your area no you know you shouldn't have
it there the book says it should be here
okay and that was the mindset we're
being taught doctrine that was being
taught in the Tradex schools at the time
going right down through the de PUE
methodology and you know he likes the
quote here and your instructors guide is
that he believed manuals needed to
express certainties clearly he thought
saw things in black and white this is
where you put deep you fight for [ __ ]
holes and this is how they're done
okay and this is where you put tanks and
this is how you put weapons to service
targets and it didn't allow for that
common sense and that's why I think a
lot of people out there had problems
with with those ideas and you know I
only embarrass you with that story
because it it's a beautiful segue
between these two issues yes it works
because you know I mean I embarrass you
with that story in my class of course I
always say it's you and not me but you
know I think it points that out and you
know you don't have to use Scotts name
but that kind of an issue points it out
again brings it down to a point where
these soldiers will understand it much
better than some you know broader
commands
one of the things I want to like to get
at in this lesson there's a tendency
amongst Tutsi GSC and I'm pretty
confident for the folks that you'll see
out there unless they've been around a
while and had a variety experience the
thing that doctrine descends on pillars
from on high that it is absolutely the
result of a rational actor model of
development rather than a function of
something a very human process where
egos and personalities and prejudices
that are involved but when I incur Burt
let your students see how that all works
I would be one of your comment about the
process how the pew gets this this book
put out on the street the way he wants
to look despite the resistance in the
army what do you think I would suggest
that goes all the way back to lessons
one and two what is doctor
what happens if someone in your
institution all of a sudden gets a lot
of power and is able to
produce one hand manual telling them how
to find what happens if the rest of the
institution disagrees with them is that
really doctrine don't forget on the
second half of the book by Herbert how
do you change is something that you
don't like what really is doctrine and I
suspect the doctrine is the collective
knowledge and experience and values of
your institution that even if someone
like Dubuque comes along and forces a
manual on you you may say
saluton say three bags full for the
first couple of years but you guys are
eventually going to turn it around and
produces something much more akin to
what your real doctrine is I like to go
back here all the way to lesson one also
where we talk about the relationship of
theory doctrine history I think this is
a great one to show how history is
related to doctor because what have we
talked about we've talked about the
impact of his experience in World War
two the impact the experience in Vietnam
the impact of the 73 war those are all
historical events and we've talked about
how that history has shaped doctrine and
how doctrine has responded to those
events so I like to take them full
circle and say you know we told you that
this was true that these things were
interacted all right and here's a
beautiful example of how historical
events Drive and historical actor to put
out doctrine whether it's accept it or
not is it really doctrine but he puts it
out and you can see the the influences
of those historical events in his life
so I I like that way to you know to tie
this back together back all the way from
16 lessons I think that works pretty
well
I like to exercise what about military
culture he has his own set of
experiences but there are people with
other agendas in the Army for example
infantry school they look at that that
manual may see very little mention of
the other kind of things the army has
has to do the contingency operations the
operations in the third world they see
it all this exclusive focus on the Fulda
gap and they say this map this manual
doesn't cut it doesn't describe the full
range of things that the artery might be
called on to do it doesn't reflect our
experience in Vietnam it's it if you
look in the annexes to the book it talks
about terrain and weather conditions in
central Germany it doesn't talk about
the gamut of things the army might have
to do and for that reason they're
dissatisfied with what's in the manual
and that's part of the rejection that
you see there there's another piece of
until out there several other pieces of
why I reject but anything will you come
in any other aspects of manual
tell us something about American
military culture the relation and
history theory not yes I would suggest
asking the students about what they
think about the process of overcoming
the 76 manual and replacing it with
something
better and what does that tell us about
where we're at today and where we're
going in the future do you in fact need
a salesman to go out and convince the
rest of the army that this new 82 manual
is going to be the wave of the future
what are the roles of the other generals
who is going to write the manual where
is it done
sometimes the manuals are written right
here at Leavenworth sometimes they're
written by The Boathouse gang in
Virginia
sometimes they're written by folks over
at Sam's who writes it why who has input
into it what does that tell us about the
institution does the air force cut off
on it is the Navy cut cut off on it how
about our allies
um
how complex has it become
I think this is this is a especially
nice and allotted effect at the end of
this year 1997 we'll have a new under -
5 on the street that at first blush
looks like it will change the way we
think about operations and I'll tell you
that again it's not it is the function
of up key players putting their inputs
in a new new strategy and new missions
for the army and again I you can use
what's coming out in 97 to look back at
what happened before bounce back and
forth to get some idea of what role does
doctrine properly play would you come
out on that now you know the thing that
has bothered me about this manual and in
the world dr. plays in this period of
time we talk about the 76 manor yeah the
76 I think it starts an argument and I
may be wrong the argument may go even
further back starts an argument that is
still alive and well in art our system
of training and doctrine and that's that
issue of training and education that we
deal with here all the time I mean this
is you know in your book you'll find
some issues under pew versus Cushman
Cushman representing though it may be an
erroneous representation of the scholar
who's looking for education it may well
be it's just a personal thing that he
doesn't agree with Depew and that's the
other side to take with this issue of do
we teach someone the how to inflate the
claim of mind or do we teach them a
broader contextual understanding of why
you use it when you use it so that you
don't teach them what to think you teach
them how to think and that's what this
course has been about and the problem
for TRADOC is that they're responsible
for
the training of the newest recruit all
the way up to and including the use of
large units are joint combined armies
and courts and thinking at this that the
strategic level to have where do you do
what piece of training where does
education come in if at all if you're
entirely right yeah and if you if you
want to get a discussion going in your
class and things start the lag in this
lesson if you want to bring out that
training versus education piece I mean
while the depute Cushman argument you
know shows it fomenting there most
groups I've been in if you start that
particular discussion your problem is
you're going to have to stop it because
it'll go on for an extended period of
time because most people have some
opinions on that issue
our students do hear about and the big
issue is why we're all here looking at
these guns because how will the US
military prepare its leaders for combat
in 2020 and 2030 what do you want to
train them to do to dig the two-man
foxhole or to think about change and how
to deal with it how to build flexibility
into the system and that's that's why
we're all here basically isn't I think
y-your honor another question might ask
is is about that that level of paper
itself is written by I heard there's a
good job I think it described the
process but I think he brings his own
prejudices to the book as well you look
at his his background the back of the
book prejudice is a strong word um we
say baggage we all bring a bunch of
stuff baggage to whatever okay called
weenie nagging
he's a light infantryman experience most
recent experience I think when you wrote
the piece
well first that that is the community
within the army that most that perhaps
react most possibly in most hostile
fashion to what if he was putting on the
76 Edition is he unfairly critical de
PUE perhaps because of its background is
he is is he perhaps unfairly praising
Cushman who had been part of that sub
community of his army out here you
realize again even in all aspects
whether it's the reserve the National
Guard or the active army that's a real
complex and wot there and people with a
lot of different worldviews involved and
when it comes up to putting a doctrine
out all those worldviews are going to
try to be represented
Herbert I think bring that baggage
baggage maybe the right word you see the
same thing in an article which which we
give our students here but we don't give
to you simply because there isn't time
and that's damn vultures goes to bomb
drop now you have the same thing you
have a successful armed war and here is
Dan who is one of the brightest minds in
the army today but it was a marked light
infantry going back with much that same
baggage that Herbert has go and get you
but this is a this is just an aberration
so there are communities within our
armed forces and you see them reflected
in our history and how they respond to
different doctrine or how doctrine gets
written based on what community is
dominant at that moment Armed Forces
there's a there's another issue I'd like
to talk about how well it's a show up my
we can superimpose it on the screen this
this is one of the most most criticized
aspects of the new doctrine this is the
active defense this is how we're going
to defend the Western Europe in the mid
70s this particular diagram is taken
from FM 7100 describes division
operations what you see is division
arrayed in the defense three brigades
across what you'll notice is there's no
reserve excuse me as you see Soviet
threat main attack coming into one of
the gate areas you see helicopters
reacting within the battle area here and
you see you see units reacting nimbly
across the division area from one
brigade to the other perhaps in contact
but they're moving in to reinforce to
quote thicken the battle as the enemy
threat comes in the Army the army looked
at this with squanders always one word
this is what I was taught this is a
sketch that he was using on that CPX I'm
going to get away from that I bring it
up the past
alright we treat it as a warning okay
and I hope you get a chance to look at
this this comes again from page five
five nineteen of the 71/100
what it shows is well we'll talk about
the reaction to this army officer look I
said wait a second units in contact
can't just pull out a contact and go
over and fight a battle another part of
a division sector and oh by the way
who's controlling the tempo of the fight
and as you fight one exelon here who's
controlling the arrival of fallen exelon
this is where we start asking questions
about where is there a need for deep
operations and why are you using your
helicopters here to fight within your
defensive area instead of going deeper
to fight the battle here controlling the
actual tempo of the fight started a
general start well no one's the first to
realize the limitations even though he
was a point man
for Depew and getting this manual
written and put out on the street he
went over to German shortly afterwards
as a corps commander he started to see
the flaws in what he helped create he
realized that the enemy in this scenario
was going to control the initiative the
tempo of the fight and he didn't have
the assets the weapon systems or the
ability to pull off something like this
and he started rethinking he's going to
be one of the leaders in rethink in the
reaction I think to that today we see at
least until the new manual comes out we
see a an emphasis on synchronization we
teach synchronization matrixes matrices
and that battle that you display on that
on that particular graphic I mean how do
you synchronize that how do you
synchronize the movement of a unit in
contact from the right side back to the
left there's no easy way to do that
there's no way to control it the lack of
using aircraft to go deep to start using
their capabilities early I think you may
see our movement towards more
synchronization to try to deal with what
we see in some of the deficiencies in
that particular page we're rapidly
running out of time here I'd like to ask
the two of you one question how has the
US Army changed from 1973 to 1997
well
let me let me offer you this this
question is a way to have students that
same person I what I do in the last
class a picture yourself in the Center
for anti American Studies in some
Hospital capital perhaps in Southwest
Asia where it has students variety of
countries in hospital United States and
you're doing a study on anti American
Studies 101 the American Way of war
based on what you learn what is it and
ask them describe what is the American
Way of war and how you take these guys
on based on what you've seen in this
lesson in previous lessons what kind of
thinking would you use what's their
style what do they do yeah that will be
one approach to tackling students coming
back at the same question how they
change are they lockstep like this are
they flexible to they emphasize
maneuvering or are they strictly about
firepower they excessively rely on
technology
those the kind of questions I think I
throw back at students to say have we
changed from this or this is really
reflect the seventies our condition who
we are well I think I mean I agree with
you those questions would all work and I
think you know the idea of the reliance
on firepower now whether I would agree
with some people have said the over
reliance on fire power I'm not sure if I
totally agree with that and the folks
who paint what occurs in the desert as
as a negative the putting together of
the fists instead of the rapier like
well you know how many guys do you
losing the rapier like versus how many
we lost in the fist and did we win oh
yes we did then I'm not sure it's an
aberration but what you were there
that's right you bring in one of the
differences I have like every historian
has baggage folks don't let me tell you
their objective to lie but I think a
major difference that I see between say
our army today and our army in 76 when I
came in is that we were totally or in a
defense when I came in totally utterly I
mean active defense it was all full of
campy as it was but it was all defensive
in nature
the Gulf War is the first time when we
step out and approach things in a large
the country large units in an offensive
manner I mean we now step out and do to
someone what we're afraid the Soviets
we're going to do to us okay we have a
much more offensive posture today I
think than we did when I came the armed
agility 6 we always focused on the
defence in 76
well we've seen advance cut of the new
manual we'll see it is isn't it goes
beyond just warfighting the way we
understand it talks about a continuing a
continual operation that it puts what we
call the past operations over the war in
the same continuum as thermonuclear
exchanges and suggest the same
principles and then attendants apply to
that it went in the spectrum as the
other now that's drawn some criticism
people in our department from students
have that I've shown the manual to how
what I think is we got approached all
document with a critical eye and one of
the tools to do that is history and that
may be the kind of thing you use to
segue into it and the finale what role
is history how does it help you get at
quote the best available thought which
is what doctrine should be thoughts a
nice
I like to wrap up the class by asking my
asking the students where have we come
and where are we going into the future
not just the United States and
Institutes of course but
the experience in general to how our
proprietary for a nation like China or
India for example what is happening in
the world today that will influence the
use of force tomorrow in 2020 and 2030
always the terms that I try to to
mention to my students I just I'm very
similar I I continue to try to tell my
students throughout the course I mean
the use of history is not just to figure
out what happened in the past but to
figure out what happened in the past and
how it can help us the future and I like
to use myself as an example
mr. Scott this time and say you know
look 20 years ago 20 plus years ago the
76 manuals what I came in the army with
I mean it's what I grew up with and I
look now 22 years later and go well geez
those are some silly things that we did
but they made all the sense in the world
then you have to put them in the person
there's perspective that's right and
what I think the successful militaries
do is you know guys like me don't you
look back too many years later and say
well geez I didn't make sense the really
successful guys look today and what
happened in the past and figure out
where it is we have to be in the future
and that's that's the challenge I try to
leave my students with with the
thought-provoking issues that are here
with the 76 manuals particularly because
you know if there's a lieutenant colonel
out there who's teaching this he's
probably about the same time frame as I
am and it goes back towards this manual
and you can use that as an example to to
say you know guys you let me learn from
the past but use it to help you look
into the future because Army's about to
change again it's coming I mean
information age technology
I mean we're 20 years from now we
probably won't recognize ourselves much
as you know the guys from 76 if they if
they win in isolation and came out
inside a day it's like whoa how this
happened so I like to leave the class
with that I like to end with a look of
oK we've seen the past but how do you
use the past and preparing for the
future
and the relevancy history
now what I would tell instructors out
there when you get to this point you're
maybe facing a big challenge I thought
is an after teaching this course maybe I
shouldn't say this run will anyway I had
teaching this course for a few years
here at CGS see I'm not sure you're
going to reach all of them there a lot
of students will walk away from military
history course and not really be able to
judge the relevance of it
what will that walk away and be able to
use military history as a tool in their
decision-making it's a jump a challenge
that they're not going to they're not
going to make accept that try to reach
the ones that the ones are curious the
ones who are open-minded and I think it
will allow for the fact that not
everybody is going to be able to walk
away from a military history course
being able to put this in their toolkit
Thanks unfortunately yes certainly right
but on the other hand there are many who
will be able to take advantage of this
Colonel Swain said the final examination
for this class is when you all go out
into the field and face change
in many ways he's right I think that's
probably as good ways I think of to wrap
this up good luck and I said I hope you
have productive and provocative
discussion classes if I think of - a
rich lesson
you